you know during the last months of 1949
one of Hollywood's most eligible
bachelors left the fold
when Jimmy Stewart was married every
bobby-soxer in America wore socks at
half-mast and a woman in Buffalo spoke
to her husband for the first time in 17
years
however Jimmy's fans are on both sides
of the screen those who work with him
admire his talent enjoy his company to
present the award to the best actress of
1949 Academy Award winner Jimmy Stewart
please forgive me for not stopping to
acknowledge how honored I am to be here
but I can't wait to see you wanted
either or soul though is nominated for
the best performance by an actress or
Jean crane in pinky 20th Century Fox
Olivia de Havilland in the heiress
paramount Susan Hayward in my foolish
heart
Samuel golden productions RKO radio
Deborah Carr in Edward my son
metro-goldwyn-mayer and Moretti young in
come to the stable 20th Century Fox now
I can have the envelope Olivia to happen
and so for the second time Olivia de
Havilland walks up to this plaque
ladies and gentlemen hi I should
describe him but anyway as she does go
up on the stage ladies and gentlemen
they can have all their critics Awards
magazine apologies but this is really
the big leagues and no one can take away
from the glamour and excitement of Oscar
and your award but to each his own
I took an incentive to venture forward
thank you or this very generous
assurance that I have not entirely
failed to do so